a lot of us have fond memories of
halloween dressing up in spooky costumes
wandering around the neighborhood with
friends while trick-or-treating getting
home with literal buckets full of candy
and then eating so many sugary treats
that you feel sick halloween is a
beloved holiday especially throughout
many parts of the united states and if
you were lucky enough to grow up in a
town that really went all out when the
last night of october rolled around then
you may have even had a local halloween
themed fairground to visit on the
creepiest night of the year scary rides
mazes and jack-o'-lanterns as far as the
eye can see but with all that said if
you lived in a certain town in the
midwest then maybe the county fair is a
little more frightening than the spirit
of the halloween season usually
encourages settle in for a story of
scares a tale of terror and a fable of
frights
this is scp-009
also known as
old fairgrounds cordoned off by the scp
foundation using huge concrete walls is
10 acres of rural land in an undisclosed
area of the midwestern united states the
place itself is completely abandoned
left silent and alone as everything
contained within those walls slowly
falls into disrepair this is all that
remains of the local county fair held in
the year
1969 and right in the middle of it all a
pickup truck crushed and wrecked beyond
all use but this truck didn't crash oh
no this was no tragic roadside accident
the thing that crushed it happened to be
a gigantic pumpkin now we aren't just
talking about a local vegetable growing
competition winner here when we say this
is a big pumpkin we are talking
huge the colossal squash has been
recorded to measure well over seven
meters in height with a diameter just
over eight meters at the widest point
according to estimates this pumpkin
known as
scp-097-1 weighs an enormous 15 thousand
kilograms
or thirty three thousand seventy pounds
to give you a frame of reference that's
about four times the average weight of a
hippopotamus the pumpkin even manages to
keep a perfectly spherical shape staying
plump and round rather than spreading
out under its own weight as you might
expect a plant of such size would okay a
pickup truck crushed by a giant pumpkin
you might be wondering surely that can't
be all there is well don't you worry
we're just getting started with this
creep show the rest of the surrounding
area of
scp-097 is abundant in overgrown
pumpkins none that quite reach the
enviable size of scp-097-1
but plenty of all different subspecies
and types on average these smaller
pumpkins weigh around 250 kilograms or
550 pounds along with various other
crops that have grown within the area of
scp-097
the pumpkins seem to have formed some
kind of maze no pun intended get it
maize like corn
these jokes are wasted on you spooky
mazes are no strange inclusion at rural
halloween fairs like this one getting
lost in the middle of the night
surrounded by rows of corn taller than a
human being is all part of the fun makes
a person feel like they're right in the
middle of a classic 80s slasher movie
where the killer could be creeping up
behind them any second
the naturally formed labyrinth found
within scp-097 has spread all throughout
what is left of the 1969 county
fairgrounds with the walls of crops
reaching over one and a half meters tall
depending on the year so
is that all a maze of crops with one
giant pumpkin at its center oh that's
far from all there is to scp-097
during the time between april and
november of every year a number of
bizarre and anomalous phenomenon takes
place within this abandoned county
fairground ranging from strange
happenings that defy explanation to
things that are downright dangerous
since they first came into contact with
scp-097
the foundation have lost eight agents to
this phenomena that occur within that
area with another 17 being severely
maimed while the exact time of these
events seems to vary the scp foundation
keeps an extensive record of phenomena
that occur within scp-097
now sometimes these will be as harmless
and annoying as the sound of drums
playing throughout the day for almost 24
hours without stopping then there's the
sightings of entities moving through the
maze only to disappear after a few short
seconds security footage the foundation
agents have gathered of these entities
depict them as what can only be
described as bed sheet ghosts the kind
you might see and immediately think of
as a last-minute low-budget halloween
costume on one particular occasion
singing was heard in the maze coming
from an unidentified source when
analyzed recordings made by the
foundation revealed that there were up
to 30 children's voices all singing in
unintelligible gibberish for three
consecutive hours another incident
involved a member of personnel on site
agent mcroy who cut a pumpkin vine using
a machete horrifyingly the severed vine
bled by that we mean actual human blood
came pouring out of the plant another
agent on a separate occasion was also
found dead within the
scp-097 maze agent long had disappeared
on the way to the restroom only to be
discovered lifeless and bloodied resting
against a pumpkin during one weekly
examination of scp-097
one agent cole broke open a pumpkin
completely by accident as the pumpkin
split apart however to the agent's
horror a child's skeleton was revealed
to be inside a human child skeleton a
little girl crouched in the fetal
position believed to only have been
about five years of age another incident
saw o'toole a research assistant working
on site at scp-097 experiencing symptoms
of nausea o'toole also appeared to be
vomiting pumpkin seeds despite not
having eaten any recently within a day
o'toole was dead seeming to have died
overnight in his sleep an autopsy
conducted by foundation experts revealed
that o'toole's chest cavity the space
beneath his ribs was somehow filled with
the same pumpkin seeds all of these
happenings are strange to say the least
but perhaps most concerning of all is
the effect that the abandoned fairground
of
scp-097 seems to have on children any
under or up to the age of 10 years old
can fall victim to an unpredictable
signal that seems to emanate from
scp-097
with a maximum range that is as of yet
undetermined usually beginning in early
april children that are affected by this
signal become afflicted with some
nombalism or sleepwalking as it is more
commonly known on clear nights these
children will wander around their own
homes often only stopping in front of
closed doorways this behavior usually
doesn't happen often at least at first
only occurring once a week however
sleepwalking gradually becomes more
frequent and by around the middle of
august it will be a nightly occurrence
if children with this affliction are
ever woken up while sleepwalking they
will scream for several seconds before
appearing confused this seems to be the
only known way to break the influence of
scp-097
however if left undisturbed a child will
spend their sleepwalking episodes
familiarizing themselves with the
doorways of their house they will stop
at every entrance exit garage door gate
even the neighbor's front doors once
they find a way outside from september
the sleepwalking children will stay
outside upright but asleep until the sun
comes up many are often found laying on
the grass in their gardens and commonly
recall having dreams about autumn season
activities between september 1st and
november 1st any affected child not
awoken during their sleepwalking will
begin to migrate towards
scp-097's location all while still
unconscious they will traverse county
roads cutting across large empty fields
as they gradually make their way towards
the abandoned remains of the county
fairground once there they will even be
able to blindly navigate a path through
the maze that surrounds most of scp-097
until they find the center what happens
when they make it to the center of the
maze any sleepwalking children who are
able to make it that far will seek out
scp-097-1 the gigantic pumpkin crushing
the truck in the middle of the
scp-097 area the children will then sit
down around the almost 23 foot tall
pumpkin and begin to sing even though
the scp foundation have managed to make
recordings of this much of the singing
seems to be gibberish or at least not
sung in any known language however music
will also begin playing from an unknown
source seeming to include a number of
basic instruments most commonly simple
drums and pipes after the sleepwalking
children have spent a number of minutes
singing like this that is when things
take a turn for the far far worse like a
charlie brown halloween special straight
out of your most horrific nightmares
from the tangled mess of plants that
make up the maze within scp-097
things will start to emerge these
entities will crawl out of the
surrounding flora or will come bursting
out from within the larger of the nearby
pumpkins they appear to be childlike in
both their appearance and mannerisms
some even wearing pajamas or similar
clothing why simple because these are
the children that sleepwalked before
they are all previous victims the ones
stolen from their families and brought
into this maze still wearing the clothes
that they were last seen in they are all
the children known to be lost to scp-097
what happens next is truly chilling the
latest child that has been affected by
the draw of the pumpkin-filled
fairground will be quickly surrounded by
all their fellow victims the other
children if they are in fact still human
children will encircle the newest child
singing and dancing around them in a
circle as they do this a dim light
begins to glow from somewhere within
scp-097-1
the biggest pumpkin in the center of
scp-097
finally at this point in the process the
newly affected child will wake up
normally they experience a great deal of
terror and confusion after all they have
been unconscious throughout this entire
ordeal sleepwalking far away from the
safety of their own home to a maze in
the middle of nowhere terror is a
powerful thing enough to make even the
bravest person let out a scream but the
moment the now awakened child lets out
any sound that is when they are doomed
should they scream cry or make any form
of vocal noise then the others will
swarm them the other children the ones
previously lured into scp-097 while
sleepwalking will attack the terrified
newcomer each time is different
sometimes they will claw at the new
child other times they might bite or
kick the methods are always different
but most often this swarm of the
pumpkin's previous victims will strangle
or dismember the latest visitor to the
abandoned fairground at this point there
is no saving the latest victim any
attempt to interfere will only fail
either the children will all become
intangible or another violent phenomenon
will occur within scp-097
stopping any onlooker from saving the
child's life when the deed is finally
done and the latest victim has been
killed by the other children the
gigantic pumpkin at the heart of scp-097
will open its side will split like a
pair of great devouring jaws and the
children will throw the body of the
newest child into scp-097
once the body has been disposed of these
entities once children that sleep walked
away from their families will follow
crawling into the pumpkin before it
closes and the music finally stops the
exact number of children between the
ages of 3 and 10 years of age who have
been lost to scp-097 is currently kept
secret by the foundation and perhaps for
all of our sanities that is for the best
like we said a lot of us have fond
memories of halloween but not all of us
now go check out
scp-823 carnival of horrors and scp
herman fuller's circus of the
disquieting for more creepy carnivals
and unsettling circuses